السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اولا اود
ان انقل لكم تحياتي واحترامي وتقديري لكل
من سال عنا لكل من تعاطف لكل من تضامن
بشتى الطرق
و هذه كلها مشاعر وصلتني بالعكس
هي وسام شرف وايضا هي من اهم الاشياء التي
تساعدني وتقويني على المواصله مواصله هذا
الطريق صحيح ان الالم كبير جدا والوجع
اكبر والثمن باهر جدا جدا جدا فحمى يعني
كان كلي وليس بضعه مني كان نفسي وروحي
وجاء بعد ان خسرت زوجتي وشقيق محمود هشام
وادم
واقاربي زميلي سامر لكن بالتاكيد هذا
الثمن وهذا الوجع لن يثنينا عن مواصله
الطريق
[موسيقى]
اكيد هذا امر صعب وليس سهل ولكن كما قلنا
لن نتردد ولو للحظه واحده ولن نتوقف للحظه
واحده طالما اننا على قيد الح الحياه
وطالما اننا قادرون على اداء هذا الواجب
فنحن سنقوم بذلك دون تردد فهي رساله
انسانيه نبيله مقدسه كفلتها كل القوانين
والمواثيق الدوليه والانسانيه
ولذلك نحن ماضون وايضا لان من استشهدوا
وسفح دمائهم ابتداء من حمزه وامه واخيه
وشام ضحوا بكثير باعز ما يملكون حتى استمر
انا على هذا الطريق وبالتالي كان لزاما
علي ان اكون وفيا بالحد الادنى
واستمر بارك الله فيكم جزاكم الله
خيرا
ه